The Joe Rogan experience. But what I was saying is like,
I was also interested in people that have dispositional a intentional
challenges, like ADHD, for example, what is that? Is that real ADHD,
a hundred percent attention functions on a continuum. Right? So,
I mean, I'd love to tell you about,
let me tell you about attention because that kind of make me feel like,
at least we'll be on the same page then. Okay. As it relates to, uh,
what I'm talking about, cuz even the mindfulness stuff is related to attention.
So attention usually, and the way we've been talking about it,
we've been talking about it is focus, right?
So what does that mean to you right now? You're laser focused on me.
You've got awesome attention. At least it looks that way. Focusing on me,
everything else is kind of fuzzed out and that we call, um,
the brain's orienting system. So I, I think of it like a flashlight.
So wherever it is that you direct your attention in that way,
you're privileging that content.
So right now you're seeing my face with more granularity,
hearing my voice with the Christmas more than the air conditioner,
whatever Jamie might be saying, you know, like right now you're focused in on,
on, on me. Thank you very much. So <laugh> that,
that actually does neurally look like it enhances
the sensory input. If you focus in on my voice, you're neurons,
as early as your auditory cortex, within a few hundred Millis seconds,
you're gonna have a clear understand comprehension,
but even just auditory, input's gonna be amplified as a function of,
of paying attention. And you know, just like literally a flashlight,
if you're in a darkened space, you know, you value that thing. You,
wherever it is that it points,
it actually gives you that privileged information.
The cool thing about the flashlight light is you can direct it willfully.
You can point it. You can also not just direct it to the extra environment.
I can say like right now, Joe, like what's the,
what's the sensations on the bottoms of your feet. Can you,
can you sense into that? Were you thinking about it before I said it? No,
I wasn't. Flashlight got directed to internal bodily sensations.
You can pick that up.
So it actually goes to one of the reasons a tension even evolved in our brain.
We talked about the evolution of distractability,
which was to advantage our survival,
but why do we have attention in the first place?
Why do we even develop this capacity to focus? And it comes down to the brain,
had a big problem,
which is that there's far more information than in the environment that it could
possibly process.
So it's got a sub sample it's gotta like get bits and pieces of what's going on
in attention, just like the flashlight. You know,
if you were in a darkened room and you kind of figure out the landscape,
you kind of scan it and kind of put together the image,
same idea with attention focus. Very important. We can talk about this,
but I actually wanna tell you about the other two main systems,
but just keep in mind that not only can we direct the flashlight,
but it can get yanked. Mm.
So if you're in a darkened room and you hear a weird sound,
you're gonna point to wherever the sound came from.
So that's the double edge sword of,
of this system is that it's not just about where it goes again.
Very good reasons that we evolve to have that. Have.
You ever done any personal experimentation with sensory deprivation.
Tanks? Oh, I wanna, I definitely wanna talk to you about that.
And actually I think that I have not. I want to, Ooh, you have to, I, I want to,
um, I just never had a chance to go <laugh> so I will definitely,
I definitely want to,
but it act actually perfect segue into the second system of attention. Okay.
Which is the exact opposite of this narrowing and privileging
and the second big system of attention. I use the,
the metaphor of like a floodlight it's called the alerting system,
the floodlight, unlike the flashlight,
narrow privileging summit information from the other floodlight,
broad receptive,
no privileging of any information allows whatever comes up to come up.
The only thing that's privileging is the now like what's important right now.
And I was when I'm driving,
I think about this often you see a flashing yellow light,
probably near a construction site or near school,
maybe what does that mean tension,
but it's not like that narrow focus attention, like broad receptive,
something weird may happen, be ready for it. So this is like I said,
it's the, this, this system is
so important and probably, and not just probably, I mean,
there's a lot of evidence that suggests in things like sensory deprivation,
you now are challenging that system because what is happening is not necessarily
from the external environment.
So whatever is the baseline existence within the internal
mail,
Milu may actually be more salient to you because just like the flashlight where
you can direct it internally, externally, or the floodlight,
you can also direct externally and internally. So in the absence,
absence of sensory input,
you're kind of in this receptive state where everything that's occurring
internally, there's an acute and rich awareness of that. Um, anyway,
so you got flashlight floodlight,
and then the third system is we call it executive troll.
It's tied to this notion of the whiteboard and working memory.
It's essentially the manager. It's like,
just like the flashlight is selecting based on content, you know,
right side or left side. The floodlight is, is selecting based on time.
What's important right now this system is selecting information cuz the whole
goal of a 10 interest to sub-sample reality, you just have different slices.
Is that, is that making sense?
Mm-hmm <affirmative> the third system executive control is,
is sub sampling based on your goals.
So what is what most goal relevant right now that should guide the way that I
perceive and act.
So this system's job and the term executive is like the way we talk about
executives of a company,
the executive's job is not to go in and do every single task,
but it's to ensure that the goals of the organization and the behavior of the
organization align and then when it's a mess up, the executive says no,
fix that. Mm. So this is where things like maintaining the goal, working memory.
That's where we put our goals.
We maintain them inhibiting irrelevant information. It's like, you know, no,
you don't need to go think about that right now. Right? Like even in the,
even in the context of a sense for deprivation tank, it's like, yeah,
that's great. I probably should remember that,
but I can't not experience this right now.
It's like goal was ex beer and sensory deprivation not go write something.
So inhibit urges we might have or behaviors,
we might have update new information,
update your goal and even shift like you are on that goal,
but get on that goal. So very complex system.
I like to think of it as like a juggler as just like all the balls are in the
air, but it's a, it really is doing this. So I,
the reason I wanted to tell you that is because, you know,
attention is such a topical thing.
Like people always say their problems are with attention.
And you were asking me about a D D and is it real? Yes.
It ends up that we have people differ along their set points of all three of
these systems. And oftentimes we see people that not only are,
are problematic on any one system, like they're too focused,
it's a dysregulation. So either hyper-focused,
you can't get the flashlight off or you're hypervigilant,
you can't stop seeing everything as required as broad receptive, almost, um,
anxiety provoking level of, of, um, of present moment awareness.
Or you just can't keep the balls in the air. There's a problem with your,
with your juggler.
So for sure people vary along these lines and sometimes they vary in their
coordination cuz these, none of these systems work alone. You know, the, the,
the executive control is telling the flashlight where to go the, the, um,
alerting systems telling you what's going on. So you need to know if you need,
so there there's this constant fluidity between these things.
So sometimes it's the coordination that gets messed up.
And when people's lives are negatively impacted,
by the way,
their attention functions to the point where it's actually causing serious
problems. That's when sometimes it gets diagnosed as a D D you know,
even before we talk about thinking what we don't do for any of us,
it's very,
very rare is teach people the value and importance of
checking out where their mind is. Moment by moment. Mm.
And going back to the people with a D D the patients that have add diagnosable,
a D that pro their life is problematic cuz of the,
this a set of set points they have on all these three systems of attention.
Those that have this thing we're talking about,
which the technical term is metaawareness,
it's essentially a version of that floodlight that I was talking about
broad receptive,
but you're checking out technically metaawareness is having awareness of
the current contents and processes of your mind moment by moment.
So first of all, to say, oh yeah, I can do that. I, I can see.
And then we do this all the time. We'd say, oh yeah, look, I'm really, you were,
you just did it a moment ago. Um, my brain's not working right now.
Like you're checking in and you're saying right now, it's not the Christmas.
I want there to be mm-hmm <affirmative> but you're attuned to it.
And so it may make you do something differently because you're aware of it.
If we're not even aware of where our mind is,
there's not a lot of opportunity that we can do anything about it.
So it ends up if you look at people with a D D that have a lot of problems,
their minds wander a lot, meaning they have off task thoughts a lot,
but they also happen to have good meta awareness,
their lives don't their lives don't suffer all that much. Meaning they,
they can,
they can have a job and do things that are kind of normal kinds of things.
So do.
Do you think we're doing a disservice by medicating people when they have that
instead of by training them how to.
Focus, you know, this is exactly where I'm going.
So that was a question I thought was a legitimate thing to ask.
We didn't wanna start out by saying stop your medication. So I involved, we, we,
one of the studies we did in my lab is that we, um,
recruited a PE bunch of people, adults with a D <affirmative> and we said,
just keep on your regular meditation. What.
Is the, what? What's the, like, what's the average medication? Like,
what are they on for the most part? Did you ask them?
I mean, all kinds of things, whether it's Stratera Wellbutrin, Wellbutrin, or.
AOL of those are SSRIs though, right?
There's some there's combinations of things is.
Wellbutrin in SSRI.
I'm not, that's not my neuro neuropharmacology is not my thing.
You can look it up. Yeah. Jamie, look it up.
But the point is that we said whatever your particular medication cocktail is,
keep on, stay on it, stay on it.
Now take this eight week mindfulness training program.
And that program was like, we started with a minute of practice,
very active practices. So now it's not sit quietly and focus on your breath.
It's go for a walk,
feel the sensations of your feet on the ground when your mind wanders come back.
So we,
we worked up to about 12 minutes a day for these adults with a D D and then at
the end of the ex uh, training program, we said, you know,
we looked at the objective metrics, looking better,
less mind wandering for the people that did the practices.
But when I just inquired,
what's different about your medication use or your mind?
They'd say before I used to take my Ritalin and then play video games for eight
hours. And I did really awesome on the video games,
but I didn't finish my homework or I forgot to go to work. You know,
like they had this raw power to focus in some sense with some of the
medications,
but they didn't have the meta awareness to know if they were using it correctly.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> after the training, that was the number one,
most consistent thing people said. I was aware of where my mind was.
I could use my time better cuz I was checking in, where am I right now? Oh,
is that tied to where I wanna be? Let me redirect.
That's also the thing that all of us benefit from with,
with mindfulness training is that not only does it connect to
using the flashlight,
it allows us to cultivate that kind of broad receptive stance
toward what is unfolding right now so that the executive
control system can update shift or redirect when things are off track that makes
the whole thing function better.
Watch the entire episode for free only on Spotify.